there was no shortage of issues to
debate at the African Union summit even
the host country Ethiopia has its own
dispute with neighbours while the
construction of its multi-billion dollar
hydropower dam over the Blue Nile River
continues it remains at odds with Egypt
over some major aspects of the project
Egypt initially opposed the giant dam
itself
now it's opposing the plan for the
filling of the lake that's going to hold
up to 74 billion cubic meters of the
rivers waters if the filling spreads
over three years as Ethiopia wants Egypt
expects to face probably the biggest
man-made reduction in its share of the
Nile waters in recorded history in 2015
if the OPA Sudan and Egypt signed the
Declaration of Principles aiming to
resolve the dispute and getting rid of a
colonial-era treaty which gave Egypt a
lion's share of the Nile but
disagreements over technical details
continue to prevent its implementation
as the dam construction neared
completion Egypt pressed for
international mediation against the
wishes of Ethiopia however the three
parties finally agreed to u.s.
arbitration last year they held several
rounds of talks in Washington coming
close to signing a final agreement in
January but after visiting the dam on
Saturday Ethiopian Prime Minister Abbott
told Parliament had asked for more time
to study the draft agreement despite
great efforts by the US president the US
Treasury secretary and the World Bank to
overcome the obstacles we still need to
negotiate this matter further during the
negotiations the downstream countries
changed their position from rejecting
building the dam to how to operate the
dam and the water flow we will continue
to benefit from our resources without
harming anyone
Ethiopia says it has every right to
utilize the Blue Nile waters but
originated from its territory for both
farming and the production of hydropower
the dam is designed to produce up to
6,000 megawatts but Egypt believes any
dramatic change in the water flows as
the dam is filled
will cause a crisis on its territory
Sudan for which the Nile passes seems
the least concerned despite warnings by
some of its senior experts of a
potentially negative impact on its water
supplies it's not clear what progress
the AU leaders can achieve during the
two days of talks while eyes are still
on Washington and lingering hopes but
the parties will sign an agreement soon
Hamid van al Jazeera